[Music]
my cello magento my cello and marchello
ordeal tell of who he is pleased the
president of the amateur astronomers
Association live from New York this is
an organization when I was a member of
this kid growing up in the Bronx not
that he's been president for that long
no but but Sir katella what most famous
alumni of the Association oh thank you
but it's assam good people in there so
she took like a plan big so how many
helmet what's the membership well it
varies with is about 900 active members
and about 3,000 4,000 actually followers
ok so we are now on we are weak we're
here on the high line and i'm on what's
the reason we're here man I mean you
guys do something we do observing we
bring telescopes here every Tuesday
every Tuesday night but on the spot
right here a little bit north of the
beyond the trees are clear yes yes and
it depends if we're looking at an object
east we may go to fourteenth Street and
look with the telephone 14 street when
we get a better view 43 cars completely
through Manhattan yes yes it's one of
the toughest like actually getting a I
oh I don't want to spoil it but I think
people might be surprised to learn how
easy it is to do astronomy in New York
City or relatively but i'd say the
sightline like finding a clear spot to
look at more of the sky because you lose
a lot of it in the tall buildings and
the trees and absolutely well there is a
little bit of planning
we want to stay away from food buildings
those are the objects we can predict
sometimes we have clouds oh yeah i know
its predictive in professional
astronomers in manhattan they have to
stay away from buildings yeah figure
that one out okay yeah yeah we also go
to Lincoln Center we're doing friday and
saturday posit in the class and next to
the fountain surrounded by very 33
peripheral buildings with light aiming
at us that was a challenge so what did
we do well we get someone who has a gun
Oh South the lights we're not advocating
for that your age to do as a kid I had
early access to high intensity light
okay and so I would go up to the
streetlights and at night you just go up
to their light sensor and you'd aim the
beam of light at it and it would turn
off because we think it was daytime okay
yeah what is the statue of limitations
on that minor contraction now that you
just confess and a green laser does it
really well if it's nowadays it's like
times and radio signals for many of us
and lasers aren't illegal green lasers
are illegal yes that's gonna be
dangerous if you poison my gosh I got
people okay your you'll have these
people no i do not i got these people I
don't have I don't have green laser
people you go to people you go to your
people are organized I'm like oh yes
exactly if you have another way you know
what I think I think wait here's your
plan my friend here's the thing i think
oh thank you hahaha start off man so i
think the three famous blackouts that
happened in New York City I think the
amateur astronomers association was
behind
they created bucket and they wanted to
force everyone to just notice stuff
right cuz of all of New York City don't
go to August anymore I wasn't here for
that but I returns all we needed oh my
god if that happens then people come out
first they're not endorse for they come
out what happened and then like stars in
the Milky Way they're all of a sudden
the sky starts talking to him